Yesterday,
the CNEWS channel underwent a real
Moscow trial.
This Thursday,
the leaders of the channel group
and the facilitators of CNEWS have been
interviewed by the
Parliamentary Committee of of the Assembly
national.
The stakes of this hearing are crucial,
to know whether,
yes or no,
the CNEWS channel will still be
authorized to emit its frequency
in deux-mille-vingt-cinq.
The 1st question is asked by the rapporteur of this
Commission,
the deputy of France insoumise Aurélien Santoul,
do you consider that Canal plus fills with
missions of public interest?
So that's not exactly the goal of a private group.
That is why Maxime Seahada,
the CEO of Canal Plus,
did not understand the point of the issue at all.
Then,
Emery Caron asks Serge Nejar,
do you know how many people
killed in Gaza by the Israeli army?
So nejar doesn't know.
And because we are brandishing this release blanket.
Except that Libé also explains in this same 1,
that this figure is unverifiable
since it is communicated by the terrorist group
of Hamas. Finally,
the highlight of the show,
if you come to my set,
I am pleased to receive you.
Thank you.
Well, listen to me.
I will gladly have a debate with you,
but on 1 other channel.